um a team i apologize for that
kuniski and and foreign now you might
have an impression from the program
description that this is heavy nyu
representation
because afonso and team are from nyu but
this is somewhat misleading because we
actually have a
strong swiss representation because
afonso now is
in eth and florent is in
um epfl um so
as was mentioned earlier the open
problem session
is cancelled uh but uh
no despair because we're gonna instead
refer you to uh
excellent collection of open problems
that have been created and discussed
during the boot camp
program late august and we will work
around
to make sure that everybody who's
interested has access
to those so that's my short introduction
um we're going to start in
in a couple of minutes with afonso stock
afonso is going to experiment with the
latest
zoom technology and the latest software
technologies he's gonna write on the
board
um and uh i've checked that so
suggestion
is i'll repeat what his suggestion is in
the video
so pin the video you're gonna see him
instead of uh
big sort of big mug shot uh and also
the board and it seems visible it works
for me hopefully it works for others
as well but just in case in parallel he
sent a link
to the in the chat that you should be
able all to see
where you can also independently link to
his
slide um as
always feel free to post questions in q
a
and i'll do my best to uh relay those
to to the speaker um
and uh not sure if there is anything
else of organizational matter
uh afonso we're gonna start in you know
one and a half minutes sounds good thank
you
i don't have other music uh as uh
prepared and i forgot about
i don't either i don't know if you were
asking me but uh no no no it was not
good
yo you already done uh you already done
your your
thing i didn't do my homework uh
yesterday ryan
filled this very important gap of a few
minutes with
with some nice music from abba and other
and i was hoping to do the same but i
forgot
my alfonzo what what i like about the
the presentation software you're using
is that with optical character
recognition i can easily and quickly
search for phrases anywhere on your
slide
yeah it's uh
we'll we'll see how well it works but
yeah with the right software you could
you should be able to transform this
into any other presentation mode
i mean i feel you know i haven't watched
the board talking so long
that that i feel like i don't know you
know i haven't watched the board talking
so long
that i feel like uh
i did just get a big echo there though
i'm not sure yeah that's
it's coming from me i'm gonna i can mute
myself but i'll have to unmute myself
from time to
time so not sure
[Music]
uh yeah but maybe we should make sure
that it's not coming from my machine
because is it is the ankle gone it's not
coming from my machine
because is it is there ankle
a test i think was
i think was david yeah
yeah so let's start i'm gonna mute
myself
but uh i'll unmute myself from time to
time to ask
uh related questions so alphonso bandera
uh
our first speaker go ahead all right
thanks so much it's a bit hard for me to
see the chat so please
if you have questions ask there and they
can can relate them
okay so hopefully this will work i
always hope you know i'm counting on the
fact that you miss board thoughts as
much as i do
we'll see if that's the case or not and
uh
yeah so this should work fine if it
sometimes zoom lowers the bandwidth and
i don't have any control over that so
there's also a youtube stream
going in hd that that that's usually
very reliable so if you go and just
change the option for hd there
it should work and you have the link in
the chat okay so
today i'll talk you know it's a short
talk more of an advertisement
about uh you know equitable colorings
and in particular
the problem of the the computational
hardness of repeating coloring in the
idea of quiet plantings
okay this is uh joined to work with uh
it's a wonderful set of uh
co-authors i think all of which are are
in this call maybe
so this is going to work with jess at
berkeley chris and santa fe and team and
alex and mike
okay and tim is going to give the the
next talk
okay so let me define the object of
study
right so the object will be a d regular
graph
right so uniform
and i'll be interested in understanding
the coloring number of such a graph
right so what happens with high
probability and so a coloring
or a vertex column right will be an
assignment
of colors to each vertex to assign a
color
that's a k option so coloring is okay
that will be a choice such that
right if note
okay this is the idea of uh just a
definition of a vertex cauldron from
from graph theory
and now the coloring number
the grammatic number of a graph is just
the smallest
smallest possible
so of course i can always color you know
within colors i can always color uh
the graph very easily just each node
gets a different color
i should say parentheses
i want to do something a little more
interesting and i want to get as little
as few colors as possible
and we know that the color the grammatic
number
is roughly something like
and so you might now ask the question
right if you're trying to understand
the computational hardness of this
problem of coloring the regular graph
you might ask the question of
okay so what about if i actually want to
be able to color the vertices in
in polynomial time or efficiently and
then we don't actually know how to do it
with less than double the number of
colors
right so if we have around d over log d
colors
it's actually it's rather easy to do it
but we don't know how to do it with less
but the question here that i'm
interested in is a different one i'm
interested in the problem of
understanding when is it that i can
refuse
the existence of a caller right so for
which
for which value of k can i refute that
there exists a coloring of size k
right so i'm given a graph that was
drawn at random and i want to produce a
proof that there is no coloring
of um right that there is no coloring of
size k right so i want to give a lower
bound
on the lower bound on the chromatic
number
okay so let me erase
this this erasing software is a little
slow
[Music]
how did you do that beautiful slide
transition is that a new keynote feature
well the problem is that you have to do
it in all of them
you know it's a good uh 30 seconds in
the end
someone should implement this on vm
alright so
okay so the question is for which day
hey
okay
right what i mean by that i mean another
way is efficient algorithm
okay so what could such a proof look
like well for example the algorithm
is just fine like you just exhibit
and click the k plus one size clip
right foot algorithm can exhibit a k
plus one size click and this is
certainly
a proof that you cannot call it with
paid callers because in particular you
would find it
an issue here right but algorithms don't
need to necessarily be
this type
right but you can just imagine some
algorithm that's what you'd like
i think some squares factor algorithms
okay so the algorithm that
you know the simplest algorithm of
course the simplest operator is just
exactly
at the size of coloring that we are it's
not clear that we can do this
efficiently or even that this is a good
idea that will provide it as well
but one one easy logon on the chromatic
number is just obtained by a spectral
value right just what's called
offman vowel right the idea being that
you know
coloring or these results in coloring
are better described in terms of cuts
right the coloring is just a
particularly big k-cut
right and so let me define
a maximum kick out of the ground
this will be
and the fraction of edges that we get
cut by
the choice of this partition right so
you can think of this as a color
okay so if if sigma is a candidate
coloring this is just a fraction of
micromedical
and so in particular written this way
the chromatic number is simply the
smallest value k
for which i can get this to be one right
because in the coloring every edge
better be like chromatic
and so this is just the minimum
yeah it seems like lots of people are
still having
issues with uh seeing you only as
um as one of the zoom videos and uh
so we're trying to resolve it so could
you i'll promise you give you
back your time okay yeah no it's fine
can you just
give the the other the the stream link
we did we did several times uh so you
can as
uh someone has to spotlight the video
but i i'm not able to do this i think a
host
i'm monitoring the stream and it looks
like it's been resolved
uh who who is that this is omid from
simon's
okay thank you so it's all result
yes okay thank you thank you so much
okay wait i didn't understand is the
stream working or no
yes yes
excellent okay thank you sorry about
that
oh sorry but is it maybe i don't know
where you can change on this side
go ahead go ahead we're good okay
okay okay so the point being that
upper bounds on the maximum k cut keep
lower bounds on the chromatic number
right so really the goal is
is that
[Music]
an upper bound on the maximum kick cut
will effectively give a lower bound on
the chromatic number
if i can upper bound maximum kick out
away from one i know that there is no
color
okay
so okay so now it's kind of clear what
to do right we just upper bound the
maximum k
cut by uh by a spectral bound
right this is known as uh as hoffmann as
hoffman's bound
okay so of course i'm not trying to i
okay and it says that for d regular
grams
kick out of g for the regular graph is
smaller equal than
okay
one minus
writing things like this for a reason
okay so written this way is kind of
clear what this noun is saying
because if i was to just pick a random
k-cut
right the number of edges they get cut
is k minus 1 over k
so this contribution just comes from a
random
j collet let's try to pick
cleverly the choice of the partition
right and this is how well
this is the deviation from the random
cup right where a is the intensity
matrix of the
of the graph and of course the minimum
the minimum eigenvalue of digestive
matrix is a negative number right one
way to see this is that the trace is
zero so
there must be both positive and negative
eigenvalues
right so this is an upper bound that one
can do and it's completely efficient
given the graph you can definitely
compute the mean weighting value
of the adjacency matrix and you know for
sure that this is an upper bound on the
maximum cut and so if this upper bound
is away from one you know that you
cannot possibly call her
with k and you can now work out what
this would give you which k
this would give which i won't do now the
next question is which
we're interested in understanding what
this does for random d regular graphs
right so for another
graph we just have to to go see what is
the typical value for the minimum
eigenvalue of it
right
from 2003 we know that the mean writing
value
a regular graph random regular graph uh
d regular graph is around minus two
with lower terms depending on n which
are not uh
so this means in particular that
we get an upper bound for the regular
graph the upper bound the typical value
for the upper bound
so this gives us the typical
effectiveness of the spectral
upper bound for uh for a deregulated
graph
and in particular now we can ask what
does it do for tolerating
does it do for coloring and for coloring
it roughly gets i mean i'm being
not super careful because of time but it
will roughly give you something like
lower order terms in lower order than
square root of t
so what this means was to see
okay so what this means is that we get a
lower bound of the chromatic number
right if we apply the spectrogram
the spectral bound we get a lower bound
and a chromatic number squared d over
two
right this is very different from d over
two of b
and so what i want to do in this talk
very briefly is to describe
evidence that we have that actually this
is an improvement
and so i'll do this in my remaining 10
minutes
there's a typo in the hoffman bound that
some people are pointing out
you have like a double negative there
like you should have plus
one plus that expression that's oh yeah
yeah there's that right you're right
thank you yes
i i did a triple negative rather than a
double negative right
the negative from here absolutely thank
you
okay so how do we argue that uh
conceptually how do we argue that this
that we that this isn't improvable how
do we
how is our evidence formulated it's
formulated in the way of uh
what we call a computational credit
planning
okay the idea being of having a
distribution
over deregular graphs for which the
chromatic number
is actually is actually a lot smaller
but which we believe the we believe that
distinguishing this distribution from
a deregular graph from a uniform
distribution over the regular graphs is
difficult
and therefore if we had an algorithm
that could
give a better lower bound on the
chromatic number efficiently
it would work with high probability
in uniform the regular graphs but he
would have to fail in this other
quietly planted distribution because
it's not
the bound is not true there and so
therefore it would be a way of
distinguishing
right but we believe that it is hard to
distinguish these two distributions
right so this is the this is the key
idea
right this idea has been used in other
another problems before
right so what is the trivial way of
trying to plant
sort of trivial that i should say maybe
naive planting
and it's best to think about these
things in terms of uh
in terms of cuts right rather than
coloring we're trying to plant a large
cake cut
and the trivial way to the most trivial
way to plant
is you pick an assignment
right so you pick some assignment sigma
possible coloring you pick sort of the
strength of your planting which will be
determined by a parameter lambda
and now you just draw a random graph
which we call the stochastic part model
with indices i guess i need a nine
d
right which is a d regular random d
regular graph
position on this choice of cut
this choice of partitioning having a
large cup
all right so let me just write the
proper equations
the edges
like sigma over
the total number of edges i'm going to
be bigger or equal than
a minus one and
one minus okay so here
i'm doing things in sort of a strange
way this is for historical reasons when
dealing with a stochastic loss model
that we think of
ada positive as having more connections
within communities than across
communities
and so really that should be negative
here
right and so just to draw a little
picture that will help
and it is basically between
in live between zero and minus one over
k minus one
and here you do no planting
okay so here this is just a normal
uniform derivative
so this is the map this is the most
naive way of making of trying to plant a
large k cut and you can see
right because of time i won't i won't
show you the calculations for this
but you can see that as of course as i
increase
as i decreasing as i make it closer and
closer to here
then i will have larger and larger cuts
potentially the graph
the the graphs produced by this blended
model
will look more and more different from
just uniformly regular graphs
another question you know one has to ask
ourselves is
for what values of eta and k do i
believe that it's actually difficult to
distinguish between these two
distributions
right so let me write that
so
[Music]
okay so these two distributions are
conjecture
and this is often known as the svm
conjecture
and is that distinguishing
is the normal uniform the regular graphs
over n vertices
and this new distribution has now a
larger k
curve and d
right it's hard
making just the hypotenuse testing
between this is hard
if d
is smaller than something which is
referred to as the casting steven
threshold
okay so now this means that i can go
all the way just shy of the place while
it's still
hard to distinguish but they're as
different as possible and whatever
cut i get there i shouldn't be able to
talk about any better than that
right and now i can go see where what is
the value of this cut
right and in particular it tells me that
i shouldn't be able to upper bound cuts
it's better than
okay now i don't have it
uh and go going back to the to the
previous slide is a little hard
but if you if you now the important
thing is that if you will look at what
what is the the the limit that it shows
on the upper bound of the maximum k
cut right there's a factor of two
missing here
right in particular what it says about
about
about chromatic number is that
it should be it should be difficult
it should be difficult to lower bound
the chromatic number
anything better than square root of d
right
but so the lower bound we have is that
square root d over 2
right and this construction tells me
that i shouldn't expect to do any better
than square root d
right but there's still a gap of two so
the point here is that
you know at least in this planting it
seems to be leaking information somehow
right because you know the i have my
my irregular graph i'm saying that
we believe it's hard to give to keep a
lower bound on coloring or an upper
bound on the chromatic number
better than square root t over two but
when i try to create at least in the
trivial planting right i'm shy by a
factor of two i'm off by a factor of two
and it begs the question of
is there anything in between between you
know square root of d and square root t
over two
where there is a better a better upper
bound not given by the spectral method
but maybe something like sum of squares
right so we know for example that test
first degree two doesn't improve
right it also stops at squares d over
two
and but now the question is can we do a
better planting can we do a planting of
a graph
that has now bigger bigger k cuts
right this chromatic number goes all the
way to root d over two
right assumes that it assumes a coloring
with a lot less colors
but for which we still believe that it's
quiet in the sense that
it's still difficult to distinguish from
the regular graph
okay so now in my in my two minutes let
me describe what the idea is behind this
and i'll show you just the construction
right so this is maybe more more for the
experts but
what appears to be happening here when
we do this kind of planting
is the same thing that happens with the
spiked uh
random matrix models and the push-out
phenomena
so if you have like for those of you
that are familiar with these things if
you have a random matrix
and you add a rank one perturbation to
it oftentimes the regular perturbation
doesn't need to be as high
as the as the right doesn't need to be
higher than the spectral norm of the
noise and still
one eigenvalue pops out of the support
this is known as this pop-up phenomena
in the in the so-called bbp transition
in random matrix theorem spike models
so what appears to be happening is
exactly this maybe another way to to
think of this is that somehow the noise
the randomness in the model
together with the planted together with
the planted cut
is creating an even bigger cut we don't
actually know if it's creating an even
bigger cut or not
but it's creating at least an even
bigger eigenvalue
or an even smaller negative eigenvalue
right so the problem here is that the
randomness in the model you can view
this as noise and the signal which is
actual coloring that you're planting
right the cut you're planting they are
not
fully orthogonal and so they're creating
something even stronger
right at least in the spectral sense and
this has been understood
well understood in random matrix theory
and so the idea is to remove this
in random matrix theory what you can do
you know in matrix problems oftentimes
you can do is you can do a planting by
instead of adding something which is
very much this type of conditioning
you can just rotate the spectrum of
course you know if you have a de-regular
graph and you're trying to rotate the
spectrum this is
this is tricky right because you're not
going to get a graph in general
and so what we do instead is we plant an
eigenvector
because if you plant something that's an
eigenvector of the matrices we care
about in particular the adjacency matrix
then for sure it will have to be
orthogonal to the other ones and so we
won't cooperate with the noise to create
a push-on phenomenon
this is exactly what the equitable model
achieves
an equitable model is just a planting of
a cut
that is an eigenvector of the gcc majors
i don't know do i have any time to just
write the model or
i mean the model itself is not yeah okay
i would say the idea behind the
motivation behind the model is more
important
but i can i can write the model if i
have a minute like
the actual plan why don't you go ahead
for another three four minutes because
we had technical interruptions so we're
gonna take five minutes from
right i have a question can you write
okay so the idea might seem a bit
strange because actually
i think ryan had a question ah sorry i
didn't hear go ahead
it was just could you write the model
please
sometimes it's also called a regular
model
this is not our intention
so it means again you pick
an assignment and you pick
a straight with the model and now to
make it an eigenvector you just make
every node have
sort of the same neighborhood right
that's what we mean by accuracy
right so in particular i'll just write
it
with each node right it's connected to d
neighbors
[Music]
or connected to the neighbors
okay so and now you just draw you know a
random
random deregular graph condition on this
right you can use uh you know you can do
these half edges and then just make some
random matching between them which is
not
not so hard to draw okay so the point is
that each node
now right it's not just that you know in
between each community there's a certain
number of edges but each node gets
connected exactly to the same
number of vertices to each one of the
communities
just a different one to its own
community right and again it's the same
thing
if i take ada to be minus one over one
over k is what makes this zero and so
you're actually planting a coloring
and if eight is zero you're not planting
i mean you're still planting something
but you're not planting a cut
right and if you think about i mean it
takes maybe a couple minutes but if you
think about you can see that this is an
eigenvector
if you if you think in terms of some
kind of diffusion on the graph
it's kind of clear at least intuitive
that there should be an eigenvector
and the point is that it is much quieter
so this is at least spectrally quiet
the sense that it doesn't create this
push out phenomena
okay and in particular it goes all the
way to the to the right cut into the
you know you can go all the way to
planting colorings of seismicity over
two
right and so it is evidence i mean gives
evidence
hoffman is optimal okay now i just want
to say
and even for you know if you want to say
if k equals two
it does suggest a way of quietly
planting
max cut onto the regular graph that goes
all the way to the spectral chart
okay so just what 30 seconds to give now
the
the the issues with this right of course
this is not real
really quiet in the right sense of
computation because it is an eigenvector
so
you can just compute eigenvectors and
you see a suspicious looking one
right so you need some kind of noise
operator so you need to
you need to have this model and then
shake it a little so that the algebraic
structure goes away
right a bit similar with with the issues
with with xor sand and so on
we're not quite sure what the right
noise operator is in particular
we're not quite sure if we're allowed to
do a noise operator that keeps the
coloring
or you can just say something about near
colorings
the other the other issue is that you
know these numbers need to be
introduced otherwise it's
hard to define the model when when d is
large
this is not a problem at all and in
particular in coloring because
0 is already an integer this is also not
a big issue
but if you want to say do k equals 2 max
cut and d equals 3
this is disastrous right so for small
values of d
this in fact yeah the the
the cut you plant for for three regular
graft
uh two cuts is next cut the cutting
plant is actually smaller than the
largest cut that's already there by
randomness
it's that bad okay so the yeah the two i
think
the two natural follow-up questions are
one
what is the right noise operator and how
can we even argue what is the right
noise operator in general in when this
kind of
extra algebraic structure appears that
cannot be seen by
by things like belief propagation and
spectral methods
and two how do we deal with small d and
i should say of course you know that
this is uh the technical contribution of
the
of the work is of course that we give
evidence that
that this is actually required all the
way to that via
sort of a a multitude of methods so bp
uh bp analysis like traditional castigan
the local statistics and stp
that yes and cena talked about yesterday
and
a low degree method type type
yeah evidence okay sorry for taking a
few extra minutes
but giving only that the positive side
without the drawbacks
wouldn't be so fair
i'm happy to take questions can i ask
you a question
yes uh yeah so um
yeah well just kind of uh answer one
question which i guess is like another
way to do it is like you take like some
kind of like barbell graph and make like
a random lift of it
this is your model maybe in the case of
cables too but
did i understand correctly that like if
you take literally what you have on the
board right now it's like
not actually quiet in the sense that
there is an algorithm that distinguishes
yes because because what you're planting
is actually an eigenvector
right right so so then what is i mean
what is the model do you have like a
model that you actually conjecture is
hard computationally hard
yeah so we we just randomly flip a few
of the edges
so what does it mean exactly so you take
you know take a small enough epsilon and
now
randomly swap uh epsilon fraction of the
edges and you can take this epsilon
as small as we want to believe if you
let the other thing
then go to infinity afterwards
but the problem so i would also
put out a limb and say that
maybe if even if you do that condition
on keeping the coloring they should
still be okay
but it starts being a bit fishy if you
start having this noise operator
depending on the planted structure
oh right so you're saying it's not
actually colorable anymore in this case
in this model no all you can refute is
existence of near colorings
i think you have to be like very picky
like do you have a model that
for coloring that you conjecture is
computationally hard
yeah so i don't know if my if my
co-authors would be uh
you know willing to be quoted on this
but i would say if you just
flip edges at random but condition on
keeping the coloring and coloring
i would be surprised if there's an
algorithm that can pick this up
but i also don't know how to argue this
right because in
you know in exorcite and so on there's
the same issue
where it's not clear how to argue that
but what we do show right the things
like the local statistics stp you know
vp type analysis degree and so on they
don't see that this is an eigenvector
right so that
we do we show that that method is uh you
know for those methods this is quiet but
of course it's not really quiet right
just like
uh xor right and those methods don't see
you know if you flip a few of the edges
they don't care
or they care only only slightly
yeah if if i can comment on this i mean
the
in this middle zone this uh
gaussian elimination algorithm is
finding this eigenvector
but it's in the so-called bulk right
it's in the bulk of the spectrum
right so there are lots of other
eigenvalues very close to it
so i guess the intuition is that even
breaking that a little bit
would confuse it with other uh
other nearby eigenvalues and have it
really get lost
but um yeah i it's not clear how to uh
approach that rigorously
right
other questions comments
[Music]
uh sithan you want to ask your questions
live
sure yeah so i was wondering whether um
you have any insight on if there's and a
plan distribution
against an additional style um
graph and the reason i ask is because
somehow if you
want to construct sos lower bounds using
planet distributions
via pseudo calibration it's good if um
your null distribution is product
yeah so i don't know how to do this for
uh for this rainy maybe uh
maybe some of the others have a more
insightful comment
yeah it's not quite clear how to you
know how to do this
yeah i guess lifts is like very special
to regular graphs
right because the plantar structure is
such right it's so
so structured that yeah it's not
completely obvious
but maybe by attempting to do something
like this for an earlier rainy graph we
might even learn how to
make the other planting less quiet i'm
not sure
maybe for that question like the
motivating principle should be
this idea of planting an exact eigen
vector so i think in principle you could
try to write down
what condition you would need on your
planted structure to make it an exact
eigenvector and that would
motivate maybe what to do but yeah we
haven't really looked at this
although sorry in the original case you
don't want it to be an eigenvector of
the adjacency matrix you would want it
to be
give you an eigenvector or a nearer
eigenvector of the non-backtracking
matrix
that's the thing whose term is kind of
controlling the ks threshold
uh yes that's a good point okay so it's
a bit more complicated than what i said
yeah
and it's hard to see how to do that with
a discrete structured like colorings as
opposed to some kind of weighted
structure
that uh compensates for the variance in
the degrees
yeah that makes sense it's it's a pretty
tricky question
even for max cut right it's not clear
how to do this for uh just just for k
equals two
um how to do this for urdish venue
and these uh kind of sdp
uh lower bounds negative results go
through this kind of more abstract
like interpolation mechanism you know
you don't really build an explicit
and explicit point so it's yeah i think
it's not clear how this spectral
i mean there is there isn't a way like
the
the completely other side of this which
is the sort of gaussian analog
of these and this we can give you know
you can define gaussian analogues of
these objects so the k equals two would
be in the character pantry hamiltonian
and this is actually what in part what
motivated us and there are things things
work but
you know in gaussian models you can just
rotate the spectrum so you don't have to
worry very much
right you just change the spectrum at
will and yeah
the distribution doesn't really change
but the point about rotating the
spectrum is that you don't have this
issue that it's not really quiet
so when you say in the sk right so in
that problem what what that would
correspond to
is having uh right having a bigger
matrix
and certifying an upper bound on the on
the quadratic form over the amplitude
right and so the value of this is like
1.5 but we believe you can't certify any
better than two
right there you can come up with a
random model i mean you can also you can
come up i guess with two random models
right one would be that you make an
eigenvector
and then draw the gaussian matrix
completely orthogonal to that
eigenvector
but another random model that doesn't
have these kinds of issues
is where you just grab the regarding
matrix and rotate
its eigenvector so that there is an
hypercube point on the top of the
spectrum
right because if you rotate the spectrum
you know you can condition on the value
of the eigenvalues and rotate
the the the spectrum at will and the
because it's rotation invariant
the the bigger matrix this is okay i
can't do this
uh it's uh it's time ready for this okay
yeah sorry i'm happy to chat uh
speaker uh thank you
thank you uh and uh tim
you you're on yes okay